Speaker 1: Farin Cousins during my break talked
about this.
And I want to talk a little bit more about
it, because this is now an actual broadcaster.
Vocal anti vaccine broadcaster Dick Farrell
has died from covid-19 complications.
OK, this was about a week ago.
I was away when it took place.
Friends say Dick Farrell encouraged them to
get the vaccine after he was infected.
So this is out of Florida.
Former South Florida talk show host Dick Farrell,
known and beloved by fans for his over the
top right wing opinions, has died from complications
from covid-19.
On Facebook, Ferrol advocated against getting
the coronavirus vaccine and was skeptical
of Dr. Anthony Fauci, chief of the U.S. National
NIH, and his recommendations concerning the
coronavirus.
Friends say after contracting the virus, he
changed his point of view.
Covid took one of my best friends rest in
peace, Dick Farrell, he is the reason I took
the shot.
He texted me and told me, get it?
He told me this virus is no joke.
And he said, I wish I had gotten it.
That's Ferro's close friend Amelie Hare on
her Facebook page.
She said, the WP TV.
I was one of the people like him who just
didn't trust the vaccine.
I trusted my immune system.
I just became more afraid of getting covid-19
than I was of any possible side effects of
the vaccine.
I'm glad I got vaccinated.
That's a good thing.
And, you know, when we talk about senseless
death, there's a lot of different things that
we could mean.
We could mean that it was avoidable.
That's one thing.
When we say senseless death, we could be this
was easily avoidable.
It made no sense.
Sometimes by senseless death, we mean it was
a death that accomplish nothing.
So if the military is waging some battle,
that is a pointless battle, that win lose
its relevance, it doesn't do.
It helps no one.
And then someone dies.
We would say it was a senseless death because
the death didn't even contribute anything
to a worthwhile cause.
So senseless death can mean a number of different
things if.
We are going to have these anti-tax people.
And some of them are going to die.
Are we better off if they are prominent and
have a platform and then it gets out that,
hey, this person that you might have heard
of, this person you listen to, they now are
saying, get the vaccine.
Does it reduce the senselessness of the death?
I think to some degree it does.
Former market general manager for CBS Radio
West Palm Beach, Lee Strasser, remembers Ferrell.
He was flamboyant, outrageous, willing to
take on any and all comers, love to engage
with local politicians pulled no punches.
Was he right all the time?
No, but he was right all the time.
Meaning right wing, especially if you asked
him, did he stay out of trouble?
Not always.
Was he great with clients?
Yes.
Was he a pleasure in the building?
Absolutely.
Was he loyal?
Unquestionably.
Was he skilled?
Yes, sir.
His passing is a big loss.
He was a kind hearted person, et cetera, et
cetera.
So a straight up anti Voxer, a straight up
anti Voxer now saying go and get yourself
the vaccine.
This is not a problem that's going to go away
anytime soon.
And particularly, I don't want to get ahead
of myself, but particularly as it looks like
at the eight month mark of your vaccination,
it will be recommended to get a third dose.
What the JNJ vaccine recipients will be instructed
to do, we don't yet know.
But for those who got the two dose vaccines,
Pfizer or Moderna, with a third dose likely
coming, this is going to be another opportunity
to have significantly more protection.
And it's going to be another opportunity for
these people to go.
They just want to keep vaccines and vaccines
in order to control us or microchip or whatever
the case may be.
So as bad as it's been, unfortunately, when
the third dose recommendations go sort of
widespread and that could be anywhere in the
next 24 to 48 hours, there will unfortunately
be even more of this that we're going to have
to contend with.